Rosa
um
I I just happen to notice that there's
an old movie festival play at the Film
Forum this week
you want to go
sure
cool awesome there's a bunch of movie
options I'll probably just go with
something classic like Citizen Kane
Citizen Kane is terrible pick a good
movie good call Smart
I'll do it I'll pick a better movie than
Citizen Kane
for the last time the best cop movies in
order Training Day Lethal Weapon and
Margo end of discussion Ron Die Hard is
the best cop movie of all time One Cop
heroically saving the day while everyone
else stands around and watches it's the
story of my life I like Turner and Hooch
Tom Hanks reluctant friendship with the
dog
that hits me where I live no RoboCop
it's got everything I like gratuitous
violence
Oh I thought you were listing things I
was I'm done
what do you need Quasimodo I gotta go
meet Boyle and Peralta
or something I don't know who can tell
you're right captain
tough weekend I went to Barbados with my
husband we wove hats out of palm fronds
and swam With The Stingrays I've never
been happier
guys impossible to read don't even try
that is without question the funniest
story I've ever heard
[Music]
the photos of your victim on your desk
is that Rosa don't worry I said hi the
puncture wounds are similar to a case I
had a while back they aren't from a
knife I think it's something spiral like
a corkscrew
don't shush me I'm helping you no no I'm
holding a baby that was actually very
helpful thank you oh
you better get back here no I hate the
vulture so much me too
but he's kind of hot
what you can hate people and still think
they're hot case in point Manuel Noriega
you know what I'm with you on this Tanya
Harding yeah she's thick right Peralta
what the hell where were you I got
eliminated excuse me officer yeah
sweetheart sweetheart seriously Hank is
how you talk to women who come in here
Jimmy Jabs I didn't make it past one
person the case is over Amy majors are
on their way to the keychain right now
it's too late has she done the double
tuck yet one Amy really likes a guy she
gets nervous and Tucks her hair behind
both ears at the same time
[Laughter]
I can never unsee that but no she has
not done that yet then there's still
time okay before we go in remember you
have to pretend to be surprised how's
this
the engine was great but the message was
flawed the guy I'm seeing
into some shady stuff right there needs
to break through follow-up follow-up so
how'd you guys meet that's a funny story
the next time
you're all done and you look hot girl no
no she was opening up Rosa figure out a
way to stay in that chair
hey Nikki I was just wondering how do
you think I would look
as a blonde like Danielle Steel novel oh
I used to see my boyfriend on Friday
nights after his wife went to bed but
then he left town a couple of weeks ago
yeah gorgeous
but finish what she was saying uh
boyfriend ran out too that's the story
for next time we're so close you can't
leave tell her you want a perm I want a
perm a big old perm
great idea let's mix it up this time you
play Amy she's in that building right
there oh you didn't do the voice it's
the Department of Records were her best
and only friend Kylie Works aha noise
she signed in 20 minutes ago yet another
great opportunity for The Voice
Amy's not here
don't give up babe you'll find me not
now Rosa hey well I did what you asked
Alfonso told me everything yes I knew it
would work
what's going on you were never my real
star Sarge but I needed to create a
scene so that Alfonso would think that
my mission had failed then I could send
in Ricky sheets DJ by night come
Smuggler by later night Alfonso started
telling me about all the crazy crap you
guys pulled in there he just couldn't
stop talking until he gave me the name
of his supplier Rosa was my leading lady
from the start she's the only good actor
here she is yeah you know nothing about
my real life I'm always acting hey hey
how long is the drive up there I want to
tie my Edibles so it kicks in right when
we arrive
what nothing it's cool I'm not gonna
tell anybody I'm not a narc all right
you can tell people good because I'm a
narc I'm not a cop anymore and I have a
prescription for anxiety so it's legal
it'll be good for when all the drama
starts why do you think there's gonna be
Drama Oh no you're right whenever we go
on one of these group trips everything's
totally normal and there's never any big
conflict anyway I'm just gonna pop one
of these right now for no reason I'm not
looking and that is why Christy and the
snobs is the best babysitters club book
ever hey
fly fishing sometimes that's never gonna
happen we need to sober you up and get
you back out there coffee and carbs
usually work so here's what we're gonna
do
herbs that was a misdirection carbs
never work slapping's the only way oh I
think it worked and I just want to say
what makes Christian the snob so good is
the snob their names are Tiffany and
Shannon and they laugh at Louie even
though he's going blind which is so sad
okay I'm calling Colt this is a failure
no wait wait I have an idea oh I bet
it's great okay you know how guys like
O'Sullivan they think we all look the
same right so you dressed as Amy you
take my place and oh my God is nine
drink Amy a genius that's never gonna
work you just need to sober up and get
back out there oh you're on the floor
okay
what's going on here uh nothing nothing
I distinctly remember you saying we're
moving on to shots and yet you bring us
more beers you got to do a better job
than that Santiago right right I guess
we'll just have to shoot these then yes
please help